here at Summer game first we caught a
behind closed doors demo of armored Core
6 fires of Rubicon Tam you're a big farm
software boy I am a big from software
boy I would describe myself as a little
from software freak I well you said it
not me yeah I'm obviously more familiar
with from software's Dark Souls
bloodborne album ring yeah the souls
bones of them armored Core is never
anything that I have but personally
played so I'm just gonna field questions
to you yeah I I will like cards on the
table full transparency armored Core is
a franchise that I've always dabbled in
and I've played multiple entries in the
series but not because I like really
gelled with them in the same way that I
gelled with and pretty much like the
from software games or you know any
other franchise I would I had like a
more of an almost academic analytical
interest in those and I did have a fun
with a couple of them here and there but
I wouldn't say I'm the biggest expert in
armored Core so if I say anything that
is like I'm actually I don't want to
hear it what I can say is it was
definitely interesting to see the
changes that they've made to it one that
are there's kind of two groupings of
changes I feel like one is the changes
that they made for armored Core fans in
response to armored Core previous
armored Core games and those are kind of
we'll get through some of that but the
other grouping of changes is the changes
they've made to how armored Core plays
to make it closer to a from software
game full transparency or like let's
just get the elephant out of the room it
is not ourselves like it does not play
like assaults like in pretty much any
measure that you would expect it to it
has some of the core principles of games
in solid legs but those aren't
principles that are design principles
they are from software principles so the
idea of challenge is is core to the
games that are from software makes now
and that is something that's very
present in armored Core it has the
similar kind of loop so I guess from a
design perspective that's the closest
you'll get to a from software as dark
soulsborne Loop the idea of facing a
challenge dying coming back and trying
again what they've done is adapted that
to make it work one for high speed
fast-paced combat and also two to really
kind of allow armored Core fans to
indulge kind of customizing cause
and building the ideal Mech for the
scenario so pulling back a bit the game
isn't fast it's not an open world in the
way that any of the other games that
they've made is what they've gone for
here is environments that are very
vertical and have a lot of density of
detail in terms of architecture and
geometry and the way the reason they do
that is because they want you to really
take advantage of the fact that armored
cores are can be quite Nimble and move
around in the environment and it's not
just when you're like engaged in
one-on-one combat or any sort of combat
it's also an element of traversal you
fight a group of enemies some of them
are simple stuff you just use your
standard like chain gun machine gun or
shoulder Cannon and then you move on
from there some of them are like bigger
boss battles but usually what you need
to do is you fight one group and then
you kind of figure out how to find the
next group and move towards the main
objective and it's not like go down this
tunnel it's like go up you know through
this hole through these that kind of
like girders in between this like
smokestack down through this like that
kind of um under this bridge and along
the way you're fighting the other part
of it is like the kind of like uh
expanse of it means that they can put
more groups of enemies and also enemies
that are quite different in how they
play and fight uh them using the melee
to take them out so I was like you hit
the button and it does like side to side
Dash that everyone loves to see real big
robots do and then there's like a blade
that you use and take them out when it
came to like one of the core minibus
slash boss fights it was way more of a
ranged game the core that we were shown
um was one that um they had like
pre-built almost and it was ready there
and the problem that one had was it was
quite
um tanky not tanky or slow
um and so what happened was they were
fighting another enemy that was quite
Hardy and also was very like damage
output up when he said it got killed
then they went back to what is
effectively the garage and showed us the
um the customization options which were
good Lord a lot there was a lot of it
it's the kind of stuff that
when you see it you're like oh this is
what a core part of the game is this is
the what the you can tell oh this is for
the people who like to make things and
like figure out how one thing works and
upgrade this part so it does this and
that is where the loop of the kind of
from software Loop kind of changes where
it's like instead of in Dark Souls where
you die to an enemy you go back you try
again this is you die to an enemy you go
back you look at the the uh character
that you have the core that you have and
think why did I die what do I have
available to me that I can add or remove
from my core to make give me a better
chance to overcome that challenge and
then you go back and in this case they
made a more Nimble one and then beat
that enemy and then moved on in the next
major combat scenario the same thing
happened and it was maybe like 10
minutes later it was like another major
boss battle and they died straight away
and it was like okay the core I made for
that previous boss no longer works here
so I need to go back into the garage and
like figure this stuff out change my
core upgrade things and I'm good so it
is that Loop but it's a loop that is
catering towards armored Core in a
little more of a natural way
there's not much Beyond it that we saw
than that there's a lot of story stuff
that was kind of coming in and out but
I'm not super familiar with the armored
Core story but I don't know the Ahmad
law um vati you can have that one for
free
um no you can't I said that the Oscar
you want a license armor the law for uh
your videos it feels like a game that
armored Core fans are gonna enjoy to me
based on what I saw but do you think
this will be the game that that truly
breaks through
I don't I don't think the wider audience
I yes and no I feel like if you are in
the market for a kind of fun smashy
robot game and you can pick that up and
it looks like it'll be very playable and
it feels like it looked like you could
get through it without like really
hitting major walls in that you would in
um in a sales game provided you engage
it with the various mechanics so yes but
also it is a very Niche kind of game
like it's not something that everyone
loves I feel like obviously this is a
preview stage but wait based on what we
saw what I saw
the people who love armored Core
they're going to see the stuff and once
they get their hands on it I think
they're going to enjoy what they have
whether it holds or holds its ground
over the entire experience it remains to
be seen I think more importantly the
good thing about this or the thing that
I'm interested or I think the value of
this ads is it kind of adds more variety
to the things that are from software is
capable of making and known for making
they don't want to be pigeonholed as a
studio that only makes sales games they
want to move away from that they want to
give themselves some sort of like safety
nets and diversity and catalog and
Longevity and the way you do that is you
explore different kinds of games and I
think this is going to be a good step
towards doing that it kind of reminds me
of Ace Combat assault Horizon which is
another Bandai Namco game in the Ace
Combat series very Niche series when
assault Horizon came out people are like
oh this is really good and anyone can
play it was basically like Call of Duty
4 assault uh Ace Combat and this
stepping stone yeah the stepping stone
to a new kind of like era of Ace Combat
this feels like it could be the stepping
stone to a new era of almond core and
it's just good to see the studio go back
to its roots they kept that franchise
alive through many many generations on a
very Niche audience and it's great now
that they have the you know the fame and
the fortune of all these sales games the
first thing they think of doing is let's
take care of the people that stuck with
us for the longest time that's just
that's just good behavior from from
software so you'd love to see it truly
yeah
more on almond cool make sure to keep
your eyes build the Game Spot obviously
the game is coming out pretty soon it's
coming out in August
um so we'll have much more closer to the
time